>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Who here is from the
Moten Elementary School.
All of you.
Terrific. Well, thanks for coming
to the Young Readers Center.
[Inaudible] part of the
Library of Congress.
Has any one of you been here before?
>> Oh boy.
>> Great. The Young Readers Center
is a special place because it's
for children up to age 16 years old.
When you're 16, you can
get a reader's card,
and that means you can go
to different reading rooms
in the library and read
books that the library has.
The Library of Congress
is the biggest library
in the world, but we are not.
We are the Young Readers Center,
and we're part of the library,
but we're much smaller
and the difference is you
don't need a reader's card.
So if you come back to visit
us, we have lots of books.
We have three rooms.
And we have books in
every room for all ages.
And if you come back and you
find a book you want to read
or have somebody read it to you,
you can just take it off the shelf
and sit in a [inaudible]
place and read.
That's why we're special.
And the other reason is that we
have programs for children like you
in which we invite special guests.
And today we're really lucky.
This is a program of an organization
called Everybody Wins D.C..
They're our partner,
and they have suggested
that your school be included, and
we are introducing to you an author
of a book called Dozer's
Run, A Dog's Story of --
I'm getting this wrong --
A Dog's Story of His Race.
Debra will correct me
with the right title.
So this is Debra Levy.
She's the author, and Rosanna
[inaudible] is the owner and trainer
of Dozer, and that's
who the story is about.
[Inaudible] at the end of
the program, you'll be able
to very carefully pet Dozer, and
we'll take a group photo with him,
but between now and
the end of the program
if you don't mind, [inaudible].
So now I'm going to
introduce Debra [inaudible].
>> Debby Levy: I'm Debby Levy,
but you knew that because
I was just introduced.
Rosanna.
>> Hi, guys.
>> Debby Levy: Dozer.
Are you all in second grade?
>> Yes.
>> Debby Levy: Yes?
Are there any first graders here?
>> No.
>> Debby Levy: Okay.
Well, we're a very intimate group.
I just might sit down so
I'm not looking down on you.
I'm very happy to be here,
very happy to meet people
from Moten Elementary School,
andI'm going to be talking about --
let me do a click here -- I'm
going to be talking about Dozer
and the book, which
is called Dozer's Run,
A True Story of A Dog and His Race.
I'm going to be talking a
little bit about writing books.
I'm going to be talking
about -- let's see --
cats and crickets and
rabbits, and you will see.
Now, Dozer is a very special dog.
And although he is right here today,
I do love looking at him up on
that screen because he's such a
good looking guy, don't you think?
Does anybody here like dogs?
Oh, okay. Wait a minute.
Me, too. Does anybody have a dog?
Really? Well, since
we're such a small group,
give me your dog's
name if you would, yes.
[ Inaudible ]
Yoey? What's your dog's name?
>> Rocky.
>> Debby Levy: Rocky.
What's your dog's name?
[ Inaudible ]
You'll get it.
It'll come to you.
What's your dog's name?
>> Zeuss.
>> Debby Levy: Zeuss?
Zeuss? I love it.
What's your dog's name?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Kujo. What's your dog's name?
>> Black? Is he black?
Beautiful?
Yeah. Beautiful coat of black?
Yes. What's your dog's name?
>> Jack?
>> Debby Levy: Jack: Very simple
and -- okay, you remembered.
What's the dog's name?
[ Inaudible ]
Ang? Okay.
Okay. Well, I'm glad
you told me your names.
Sometimes I collect names because
then you never know in a book
that I write in the future, and
I've written a lot of books,
I might remember one of these
names and use them in a book.
So stay tuned.
So back to Dozer.
There's the book I wrote about him,
and I'll be talking more about them.
And Dozer is famous.
He's famous.
He's very special.
Yeah, he's famous.
I'm going to tell you about that.
He's also special because --
do you think any old dog can go
into the Library of Congress?
No. Do you think dogs can
normally go to hospitals?
Dozer can.
Do you think dogs can
normally go to schools?
Dozer can.
He's on his way some place
right there in that picture.
Here he is on television.
He's been on television across the
land, across the United States.
He has so many friends and fans.
Dozer has seven -- more than
17,000 friends on Facebook.
But don't -- that's his
Facebook page right there.
I thought if I told you he
had more than 17,000 fans
and friends you wouldn't believe
me so I included the number that's
on the internet right there.
>> And I'm also one of his friends.
>> Debby Levy: You're
one of his friends.
Thank you very much.
He also has friends and real
people like these people who got
to meet him and many, many more.
So we've established that we
all like dogs or most of us,
but let us not neglect
other animals.
Does anybody here like cats?
I like cats.
I have a cat.
That's my cat.
I wrote a poem about a cat.
We're going to -- I'm going to
give you time to ask questions
after I've blabbed
a little bit, okay?
But there will be time
for questions.
So I wrote a poem about
a cat, not this cat.
But that cat in that book, which
I also wrote which is right here.
Maybe I'll Sleep in the Bathtub
Tonight, and I'm going to start --
we're going to start with me reading
this poem because there's a role
for you all in this poem, too.
The poem is about a cat, yes.
But it's also about a cricket.
And a cricket makes
what kind of sound?
Chirp, chirp, chirp,
chirp, chirp, chirp.
Am I right?
All right.
Can you chirp?
When I go like this on the
poem, when I raise my hand,
that's your time to say the line
in the poem, which is chirping.
So you're going to chirp.
Let's practice.
Okay? Chirp, chirp, chirp, chirp,
chirp, chirp, chirp, chirp, chirp.
What? Chirp, chirp, chirp, chirp.
One more practice.
Chirp, chirp, chirp, chirp.
Oh, that's beautiful.
Here we go.
The poem is called The Cricket.
The Cricket.
Chirp, chirp, chirp, chirp, chirp.
The cricket chirped.
I thought it sounded cute.
Chirp, chirp, chirp, chirp, chirp.
Okay. Enough, now scoot.
It didn't scoot.
I couldn't sleep neither
could Chester, my cat.
I nudged Chester off the bed and
said, "Go, put an end to that."
Chester pounced, and I called
out, "Swat it, Chester.
Swat it!" I cheered my cat
[inaudible] the dark I thought
that he had got it.
Chester got the cricket, yes.
It jumped into his mouth.
But didn't stop and hopped
inside of Chester heading south.
Once the cricket reached his
belly, Chester gave a burp and ever
since when Chester purs, he goes
chirp, chirp, chirp, chirp, chirp.
Now, I love poems that rhyme,
and that poem in that last verse,
what word rhymed with chirp?
Burp. Burp.
Once the cricket reached his
belly, Chester gave a burp and ever
since when Chester purs, he goes
chirp, chirp, chirp, chirp, chirp.
Can you think of any other
words that rhyme with chirp?
Yeah, what do you think
rhymes with chirp?
[ Inaudible ]
[Inaudible]?
Is that a word?
No. Slurp.
Good one because I was about to
say I can't think of a single word
that rhymes with chirp,
and there you go.
You did. Well done.
And you know what?
We're all natural poets in a way.
So if I were to make up a poem about
an apple and I say an apple is red
and round, you plant
its seed in the --
>> Ground.
>> Debby Levy: Ground.
The seed grows into a tree.
New apples for you and me.
We're all natural poets.
It's amazing.
Okay. Enough about
cats and crickets.
Rabbits. Any of you have rabbits?
Yeah? Do you have a rabbit as a pet?
Well, I don't.
But I wrote a book about a rabbit.
Oh, do you think this book
that I wrote about a rabbit
that I called Tab for some reason
is on the library shelf here
at the Library of Congress?
It's not.
You think it's on anybody's
shelf at all?
No. I wrote it when
I was little, though,
because even when I was
little, that's me being little.
I was interested in writing books.
And so I started writing books.
Here's one that I wrote
when I was 7 years old.
Something Happens to Tuggy.
That's not Tuggy on the cover.
That's Tuggy, Tuggy the tugboat.
And let's see.
Here's another, The Captured Boys.
I know what you're thinking.
You just -- I already know
that what you're thinking is
that this woman cannot
draw or color.
And it is true.
I'm not an artist.
So get that out of the way.
You don't have to feel sorry for me
because I know that it's the case.
So this is my first book that's
a nonfiction book called Fish.
Who here can tell me
what nonfiction is?
What's nonfiction?
[ Inaudible ]
Something that's --
something that's real, yes.
A nonfiction book is a book that's
an information book, that's true.
It tells a true story.
My Dozer book tells a true story.
What's the opposite
of a nonfiction book?
Yes. A fairtale is not a -- is
a -- the opposite of nonfiction.
What else?
Fiction is also the
more general term.
So fish is supposed to be my
first effort at nonfiction and so
for there are many kinds of fish,
there are much more than listed.
So far so good.
Yeah. Nice drawings, huh?
You know when they're dead because
he lies on its sides on the bottom.
Well now. You could spend an
entire week in school learning
about all the mistakes in
the sentence that I wrote.
Who here can tell me
something wrong,
some of my mistakes in my sentence?
You know when they're dead because
he lies on its sides on the bottom.
Anybody? Yes.
>> Sides.
>> Debby Levy: He lies on its sides.
Can you lie on both your
sides at the same time?
Kind of a problem.
What else?
[ Inaudible ]
You can lie on one side at a time.
An here's another thing.
You know when they're
dead -- I say -- yes.
>> Its.
>> Debby Levy: So I say he lies
on its sides on the bottom.
So here I'm talking about fish,
and I'm talking about they
as if there's lots of them.
I'm talking about he,
and I'm talking about it.
I should have chosen just
one way to talk, shouldn't I?
If it's a he, then he lies
on his side on the bottom.
But you know what?
This leads me to one of
the most important things
that I've learned in writing books.
And that is the importance
of making mistakes.
Do you ever make mistakes?
Yeah. Yeah, we all make mistakes.
And when you make mistakes, you know
that you're doing something
new usually.
You're trying something new.
That's a good thing.
You make mistakes.
You learn from your mistakes.
So I encourage you all not to
be afraid to make mistakes.
It's usually because you're trying
something new and you're going
to learn and very often you
can also correct your mistakes
and make them good.
So one more page.
Fish tanks should not be carried.
A lot of the fish get dizzy.
Okay, this is a nonfiction book.
True or false.
Fish tanks should not be
carried a lot if fish get dizzy.
What do you think?
True? False?
True. What does anybody else think?
What do you think?
False. I have no idea.
I made it up, which
you're not supposed to do
when you write nonfiction,
but I have learned
and I do try not to do that anymore.
Okay. So Dozer's saying,
"Are you kidding me, already?
Enough with the crickets
and the fish and the cat.
Let's talk about me."
So rather then just talk about
him, I'm going to read you part
of this book, Dozer's Run, which I
wrote about him with Rosanna's help,
and this is a book you're going
to take with you, your own copies,
when you leave here today.
So are we ready?
I'm ready.
Dozer's Run, A True Story.
And I'm going to show the pages
up here, then I'll read it here.
It was a dark -- it was a damp and
drizzly Sunday morning in Dozer
and Chica's neighborhood.
Who knew what delicious smells
last night's rain washed in?
Who knew what treasures the
storm blew into the yard?
So the two best friends stretched
out after a good night's sleep
in the barn, shook themselves
off and began to investigate.
Out in the street a runner ran by.
Then, another runner and another
and another and another and another.
Where were those runners running?
Dozer and Chica looked
at each other.
Then they got back
to their exploring.
Was this big branch here yesterday?
A raccoon was there.
Wow, the whiff of wet wood,
frog here in this hollow,
more runners ran by.
Where are all those
runners running ?
"We stay in the yard,"
Chica said with her eyes.
Dozer's eyes were on the runners.
"We belong in the yard,"
Chica's eyes said.
Plus, we haven't had breakfast yet.
Later. We'll walk with our people.
"But the runners are running
now, Chica," Dozer said
with his big swishy tail.
They must be chasing
something wonderful."
"More wonderful than the flavor
of frog and the wreak of raccoon?
More wonderful than
breakfast, Dozer?
Dozer did love his breakfast.
But he had to find out what
the runners were chasing.
He dashed out of the yard.
"I'll be back, Chica!"
Follow the leader.
But who was the leader?
Dozer followed his nose and
smelled a pocket full of gummies,
shorts with a scent of strange
dog, stinky socks, tangy trailmix,
sneakers that once
stepped in never mind.
Dozer followed his ears.
He heard laughter,
whistles, wonderfulness.
And lots of leaders.
Dozer could be a leader, too.
Dozer kept his head
high and his tail proud.
Around him, people were drooping.
Some were slowing down.
These runners needed him.
Come on, one foot after another.
You can do it.
We'll be some place wonderful soon.
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
Suddenly, Dozer heard
clapping and cheering.
He slowed down to investigate.
He looked right.
He looked left.
He looked straight ahead
and oh, Dozer sped up
and scampered across
the finish line.
"See? I knew we could do it.
I knew we were running
some place wonderful."
The other runners smiled
and chatted and high fived.
They all got big shiny
metals hung on broad ribbons.
Friends and families greeted them.
Everyone was happy and crowd.
But no one greeted Dozer.
No one smiled and chatted
and high fived with Dozer.
No one gave him a big shiny metal.
No one even gave him a
teeny tiny dog treat.
Oh, suddenly, this
wasn't so wonderful.
It wasn't wonderful at all.
So Dozer ran on.
Morning turned into
afternoon turned into evening.
There was no leader
for Dozer to follow.
There were no followers
for Dozer to lead.
Dozer was alone.
He was alone all night long.
That's as much as I'm
going to read right now.
You can find out exactly what
happens when you read the book.
I'll talk a little bit about what
did happen in a minute, but tell me.
What do you think Dozer
might have done all night?
Keep in mind these things.
He's far from home because
he's been running a long time,
didn't have any breakfast.
He's lost.
Any ideas about what
maybe Dozer did?
I'd like to hear them?
What do you think Dozer
might have done?
[ Inaudible ]
He might have been running
and looking for the runners.
Because he didn't know.
Maybe the runners are
running at night.
What was your idea?
[ Inaudible ]
He was looking for a
home, another good idea.
What might he have done?
[ Inaudible ]
He wanted to know where
they were going
so maybe all night he kept
looking and running, right?
Anybody else's idea?
Anybody have any crazy
and wild ideas
for something he might have done?
No? Maybe he knocked on somebody's
door and they let him in?
No. Maybe he -- I don't know --
went to McDonald's and
had some chicken tenders?
No, no. Well, any of
those wild ideas or any
of your ideas are good ideas but
they couldn't have gone in my book
because my book is
nonfiction, meaning it's true,
and we don't know what Dozer did.
We don't know.
And we're not going to know
until he learns how to talk.
So Rosanna, please teach him.
Now, Dozer, if you had been
in Dozer's shoes that day,
and you had seen these runners
running past his front yard,
you would have seen clues that
would have given you an idea
of what was going on.
Can you tell me what clues
you might see in the picture
that would clue you
into what was happening?
What do you think, young man?
[ Inaudible ]
It's a race.
It's an organized race
because yes, what do you see?
[ Inaudible ]
Maybe -- actually you're right.
You can tell that they're
running in an organized race
and if they finish will get a medal.
You also have an idea?
Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
Dozer felt left out because
he didn't get a medal also.
What do you have?
[ Inaudible ]
Dozer probably was doing --
following because he smelled
good things, and in fact,
people that run races and what I
learned, what Dozer didn't know is
that this was an organized race
called the Maryland Half Marathon.
You know how long a
half marathon is?
13 miles. Have you ever
run 13 miles at one time?
I don't think so unless
you've run a half marathon.
And a lot of people
-- you were talking
about Dozer following
his nose and smells.
A lot of people when
they're running that far,
they'll carry in their arm bands
or in a little pouch little snacks
like jellybeans or trailmix
or things like that.
Now, 2000 people ran
the race that day.
So can you blame Dozer for
wanting to leave his yard
when he saw 2000 people
running by one after another?
And a lot of people
saw Dozer running.
Some of the runners did, of course,
but so did people along the race.
And they took pictures
of him running.
Those are some of the
photos from Dozer running.
And more. Here's Dozer running.
More running.
I'm still running.
He's running.
And there he is about to
cross the finish line.
He ran a very long way.
Now, here you can see the real
life photo of the finish line
and the art work from the book
showing him approaching the
finish line.
Now, do any of you have
runners in your family?
Anybody? People run --
who runs in your family?
Your sister runs long distances?
Short distances?
Long? Who runs in your family?
[ Inaudible ]
You and your uncle run?
That's so cool.
Who runs in your family?
>> Mom.
>> Debby Levy: Your Mom runs?
Wow. You all come from fit families.
I'm happy to hear this.
Who runs in your family?
Your Dad runs?
Very cool.
Well, a lot of time these races
like the Maryland half marathon,
they are run for the fun of
running, for the exercise
of running, but also to do good.
So they raise money
often for a good cause.
The Maryland half marathon
raised money to fight cancer.
Just by your hands, do
you know what cancer is?
It's a disease.
It effects a lot of people.
And so research needs to be done,
and people need to be taken care of.
So the runners, they get sponsors.
They get sponsors to
pay, give money to --
in this case, a cancer center in
Baltimore in honor of their run
and that's how lots of money
is raised to fight cancer
and people also get to go
out and have a good time.
Now, so these runners, all of
them were also philanthropists.
It's a hard word to say, but
it's easy for you to understand.
First, let's see if you can say it.
Philanthropists.
>> Philanthropists.
>> Debby Levy: Say it.
>> Debby Levy: Philanthropists,
philanthropists, philanthropists.
Philanthropists, philanthropists,
philanthropists.
And all that is is
somebody who does --
who does for others,
who gives for others.
And it doesn't have
to be piles of money.
So for example, it can be doing
something good in your neighborhood.
Now, do you think a dog --
do you think Dozer could
be a philanthropist?
[ Inaudible ]
I mean, he didn't go
out and get sponsors.
He didn't go out and raise money,
but all during the race, he helped.
His cheerfulness helped
people keep going
because it's hard to run 13 miles.
His funniness -- he
made people laugh
because he can be a
little bit goofy.
So he made people laugh, and
they wanted to finish the race.
So what happened after the race
was over and Dozer was missing
for 24 hours -- you
know how long that is?
A full day from Sunday
morning to Monday morning.
Of course, Rosanna was
worried to death about her.
But all the people who had seen
Dozer, they were talking about him.
So they're talking
about their neighbors.
Rosanna's calling people.
The race organizers are
talking about this dog.
Finally, Rosanna and the
race organizers realized
that Dozer was the dog that
everybody was talking about.
So the organizers decided that
Dozer who finished the race,
he started at mile five and ended
at 13 so how many miles did he run?
Hard for me, too.
Eight miles.
He ran eight miles.
That's a long way.
So they decided he
should get a medal.
Here he is, the medal is being
put on him and he's thinking,
do I really want this on my neck?
I don't know.
And there he is telling his Mom,
yeah actually I look pretty good.
So then word really started
to spread about Dozer,
not only among the runners but
throughout the state of Maryland,
throughout the whole country.
And people started making donations
to fight cancer in honor of his run.
And what happened was 700 people
from 43 states including Washington,
D.C. and three countries made
donations totalling $25,000
to fight cancer.
So Dozer raised two times as much as
any of the human runners in the race
that day because nobody raised
nearly as much money as Dozer.
And that is what made him
famous, and that is why he's
on television, why
he has so many fans.
He's a good boy, and now I'm
going to get back to a mistake.
It was a mistake for him
to leave his yard that day.
It was a mistake.
He shouldn't do it again.
Dozer, don't do it again.
But he and his Mom and everybody
who knew him, they turned it
into something really, really good.
I'm going to tell you a tiny bit
about how I came to write this book.
Somebody told me about what
happened, just the vaguest details.
Some dog ran some race some place.
It's interesting.
Maybe you want to write
a book about it.
So I did some research.
How do you think I
started my research?
How do you think?
[ Inaudible ]
I looked it up on the computer.
That's exactly right.
I learned that Dozer was in
Maryland and I'm from Maryland.
I learned a little
bit, but then I need
to go meet Rosanna, and
I talked to Rosanna.
I talked to others too about
what happened that day,
but I knew I wanted to write a
book from the dog's point of view.
So remember when I wrote --
when I read from the book?
You've got Dozer's point of
view and what he's seeing
but mostly what he's smelling.
I really wanted to get in
Dozer's head and to do that,
I needed to interview Rosanna.
So you all, think about if you're
the writer and you have this idea
to write a book about
a dog about Dozer.
Let's you interview Rosanna like I
did and ask her questions that you'd
like to know or that you'd want to
know to write a book about Dozer.
Any of you have some
questions about Dozer?
Well, I can start.
I can start.
>> Okay, go ahead.
>> Debby Levy: Why
is he called Dozer?
>> That's a great question.
He's called Dozer because when he
was a little puppy he had bigger
paws than his body, and
when he used to run,
he used to dozer down the hill.
>> Debby Levy: Like a bulldozer?
>> Like a bulldozer.
So we ended up calling him Dozer.
>> Debby Levy: What's your question?
[ Inaudible ]
How old is Dozer?
>> Dozer's seven.
>> Debby Levy: Seven?
But how old was he when
he ran -- he was seven.
He was three.
Yeah. He was three
when he ran the race.
He was a puppy.
When is Dozer's birthday?
>> You know, I think in
the book we put March 2.
>> Debby Levy: I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't see it.
>> It's March 2.
>> Debby Levy: I never
asked that question.
That's a good question.
Who else has a good question
for Rosanna about Dozer?
Yeah. What's your question?
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah. Why was Dozer so
interested in running?
>> Dozer loves to run.
He loves to run.
I'm not sure.
He's a people lover so I think when
he saw so many people running by,
he wanted to join the momentum.
You know what momentum is?
>> No.
>> Debby Levy: It's
a forward motion.
They were moving forward, and
he wanted to move with them.
>> It's whenever --
has some momentum.
So when you feel it's
an energy of momentum.
So I think he just felt that
and wanted to go, go for it.
It was a positive momentum.
>> Debby Levy: Anybody else have
questions for Rosanna about Dozer?
You're writing a book.
You got to find out about him.
Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
How old is Dozer?
Dozer's 7 years old.
Anybody else?
>> He was 3 years old
when it happened, but 7.
>> Debby Levy: What's your question?
[ Inaudible ]
We don't know when his birthday is.
>> It's March 2.
I celebrate two birthdays, when
he was born and when we got him.
>> Debby Levy: Lucky Dozer.
>> The [inaudible].
So some of you'll see as
February, but it's really March.
>> Debby Levy: Did
you have a question?
[ Inaudible ]
Why is Dozer a special dog?
>> I think he's special just because
I love him because he's my dog.
But I think the rest of the
world thinks he's special
because he did good
for a lot of people.
He raised a lot of money for cancer
research, but it wasn't just him.
It was through everybody
that supported the cause.
So that's what made him special.
>> Debby Levy: What's your question?
[ Inaudible ]
Good question.
Does Dozer have friends?
>> I would say yes.
He has over 17,000 Facebook friends.
>> Debby Levy: Does
he have dog friends?
>> Oh yeah.
He's got lots of dog friends.
He has a friend named
Chica, which is in the book.
That's one of his best friends.
He goes do playtime
all the time with her.
And then he just has -- he
just got a brother named Trent,
and he's a real big -- oh.
Cool. He's an English Mastiff,
which is really, really big.
If you go on his Facebook
page, you'll see him a lot.
He does photo bombs
behind Dozer a lot.
He shows up.
So you'll see him, too.
>> Debby Levy: What's your question?
[ Inaudible ]
How do you make a book?
I'm so glad you asked that.
Let me tell you a little bit
about how this book was made.
There it is.
There's Rosanna, the
day I interviewed them,
when I first met them.
So after I did all my research
which included talking to Rosanna
but other research as well like
talking to other people and learning
about what it's like to run
a half marathon and learning
about goldendoodles, which is the
breed that Dozer is, I wrote my --
I wrote a draft, and that's
exact -- that is my draft.
That's a shot -- a screenshot
from my computer at home.
And it's all nice and
neat, isn't it?
You think we're ready
to publish the book?
Since I have such a nice draft?
>> Yes.
>> Debby Levy: No.
We're not ready to publish
the book because I had
to tear it all apart and rewrite it.
I rewrote and rewrote.
When you write a paper,
maybe now you write it once.
But as you go through
school, you'll do rewriting
because you can usually improve on
the very first thing that you write.
Certainly, I can.
There's some of my improvements.
And there's more I did.
Oh, my goodness.
I did a lot of drafts.
Finally -- finally, I was happy
with the words that I had written.
What's your question?
[ Inaudible ]
I did print it out.
I did print it out, but I didn't
want to bring all those printouts
with me because I'd be
walking around like this.
There were so many of them.
So mostly I work -- I
do work on my computer.
I print things out and sometimes
I work with a pen or pencil.
What's your question?
[ Inaudible ]
Why is Dozer a special dog?
Because everybody likes him.
He has lots of friends.
What's your question?
[ Inaudible ]
What type of dog?
That's a good question, and
I only said it too quickly.
He's a goldendoodle.
What's a goldendoodle?
>> It's a mix between a
golden retriever and a poodle.
>> Debby Levy: So once I got
the words as I wanted them,
then are we ready to make the book?
>> Yeah.
>> Debby Levy: Yes, but
no because pictures.
You saw my pictures of Tab the
rabbit and the captured boys.
Did I make the pictures
for this book?
I did not.
See that -- that's right.
The illustrators, a guy named
David Opey [assumed spelling].
There he is.
There we all are.
Team Dozer.
And illustrators too --
questions after I talk
about this a little bit --
illustrators too, they
don't just sit down
and illustrate a book
and here it is.
It's already to go.
They go through a lot
of steps too so Dave,
he made lots of different
sketches of Dozer
to get just the right shape.
Dozer moving, Dozer sitting.
Then he worked on what he calls
color studies to get the color
that he wanted because
you know what?
Let's use a word.
What color would you say Dozer is?
What would you say?
[ Inaudible ]
Some kind of white?
Yeah. What would you say?
Golden white.
I see.
>> White.
>> Debby Levy: White.
What would you say?
>> Golden.
>> Debby Levy: What would
you say his color is?
>> It's kind of like skin color.
>> Debby Levy: It's
kind of like skin color.
Somebody's skin color,
but it's not just white.
It's not just gold like most of us.
He's all different
colors rolled up together
and so the illustrator did a
lot of studies trying to figure
out what he should look like.
Then, he puts together more detailed
sketches like the one on the left
with his final art for the book.
Takes a while, takes months.
And then finally we do have a book.
So we've got our award
winning Dozer.
Now, do you think the Library
of Congress lets any old dog
into the Library of Congress?
No. They don't.
And remember I told you, do
you think any old dog can sit
through a presentation like he has?
He might be saying, "Oh,
I got to get out of here.
I got to move.
Let's go. Let's go.
Where's my [inaudible]?"
Can I say that word?
>> Yeah, he's --
>> Debby Levy: So Dozer is a special
dog also because he has a job.
Dozer's a therapy dog.
And I'm going to be asking,
interviewing now Rosanna
about Dozer's life as a therapy dog.
And this isn't the book
because when Dozer ran away
and did his run, he
wasn't a therapy dog.
Only afterwards did Rosanna
decide to get him certified
to get him recognized as a therapy
dog so that he could come to places
like this and so they could do --
continue to do good
things for other people.
So now there are philanthropists,
philanthropists, philanthropists
in a new way by going
and helping people
because Dozer's a therapy dog.
And a therapy dog -- does anybody
know what a therapy dog is?
Is one that's trained specially to
work with people and be with people
who are maybe sick or very old and
frail or people who have problems,
whether they have drug
problems or alcohol problems
or maybe they've been
through a terrible experience,
a disaster like a flood or
a hurricane and therapy dogs
with their humans, they go and visit
these people and work with them,
and they do a lot of good.
And therapy dogs are always
very gentle and kind and smart.
And let's learn more about Dozer
the therapy dog from Rosanna.
So Rosanna, what would you say
is the most important quality
that a dog has to have in order to
get the job of being a therapy dog?
>> I would say he has to
be able to be patient.
It's very important
like he is today.
And mostly calm.
>> Debby Levy: Do therapy dogs
have to be a particular size?
Do you have to be a
nice big dog like Dozer?
>> You can be any size.
Therapy dogs come from little --
tiny little pups to
really big, big ones.
>> Debby Levy: And what does
a therapy dog do in its job?
>> A therapy dog helps
people in different ways.
That's why their title is therapy.
It gives each person depending
on what their needs are.
It's therapeutic.
So some people are nervous people
or anxious, and I'll bring Dozer in,
and it kind of calms them down.
Some kids are in the hospital.
They've been in there for a
long time and they get depressed
and upset because they
haven't been outside a lot.
So they get really happy
when they see Dozer,
and Dozer brings them
a lot of happiness.
Sometimes we go into nursing
homes where the patient had
to leave their dog at home or their
animal at home and hasn't seem them
for a very long time because
they've been too sick to go home
or they're probably not
going to be able to go back.
So when Dozer comes in, it
makes them really happy.
They remember their pet.
>> Debby Levy: Does a
therapy dog work by himself?
Do you take him in and then
send him into the room?
>> No. A therapy dog has
to have a person with them,
and the person trains them to do
basically just to be good to others
and therapeutic, to give
others what they need.
Lots of love, loves of attention.
>> Debby Levy: What do you like
most about doing the therapy work
about being Dozer the
therapy dog's Mom?
What do you like most about
the work of a therapy dog?
>> I like mostly that we're
helping people, that we make --
we always leave there
with people smiling.
Everybody's happy when
Dozer comes in.
Everybody always wants
to see us come back.
So it's a great feeling
to help others.
>> Debby Levy: Does
anybody have questions
about the therapy dog
part of Dozer's work?
And we'll get to all your questions
if you have any in a minute,
but anything about him
being a therapy dog?
Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
What does he do when he actually
goes into to do his therapy?
So I guess what does he do when
he's with an older sick person?
What does he do with
the younger person?
>> Dozer just goes with the flow.
So it depends.
For example, if we
came to your house,
what would you want
to do with Dozer?
What's your favorite things to do?
What do you like?
Let me start with -- what's that?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Playing.
Well then, he would play with you.
What's your favorite
thing to do with dogs?
[ Inaudible ]
>> He loves that.
He loves to eat and walk so
he would do that with you.
[ Inaudible ]
>> He does that, too.
He'll throw things.
He'll catch it, and he'll
bring it back to you.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Tricks.
>> Debby Levy: Does
Dozer do any tricks?
>> He does a couple tricks.
He -- Dozer, come up.
Up. So Dozer will sit.
Sit. He gives paw.
Give me your paw.
Good boy. Lay down.
Lay. Dozer, lay.
Lay. Good boy.
That's pretty much what
he does for right now.
I don't know if he'll do the other
ones because -- and he listens.
He listens real well.
But Dozer will do pretty much
anything depending on where we're at
and what the situation is
and what your needs are.
You like to throw the ball.
She likes to -- what did
you -- play with him.
She wants to eat --
feed him and walk him.
So he pretty much just
wants to make people happy.
That's why he's a great therapy
dog because he's a people pleaser.
He wants to make you happy.
>> Debby Levy: What
does Dozer like to eat?
>> Dozer, believe it or
-- he eats real food.
>> Debby Levy: Real food?
>> Yes. I cook him real food.
There are certain things dogs can't
eat, but he'll eat vegetables, meat,
rice, all kinds of stuff.
>> Debby Levy: Does he like chicken?
>> Chicken, fish,red meat.
No. No bones.
He likes chewing on the bone.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Debby Levy: Human food.
Your dog too likes to eat --
>> Why not?
Right? Good stuff.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Debby Levy: Doesn't
just eat pet food?
Only eats pet food.
[ Inaudible ]
He eats human food too.
>> I don't blame him.
>> Debby Levy: People
give their dog human food.
Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
When Dozer runs, what?
>> He does have a medal.
We have it at home, and
I didn't bring it today.
He does. You'll see it.
He has it right there.
I have it in a case at home,
but he did get a medal.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Debby Levy: Dozer's famous.
He is because he was on -- he
was on television on the news,
not just here, but national news
all across the United States
and even people in
Canada heard about him
and in other countries as well.
I'm going to show you one more
thing, and then we're going
to have more questions and then
we're going to get to meet Dozer.
So you saw my books from earlier
about the captured boys and Tuggy
and Fish, but I have also written
other books that are published
like the Dozer book,
and here they are.
I've written 22 books in total.
I don't know if you've
seen any of them.
Some of them are up here, and
they're pictured up there.
I wrote a book about -- oh, I've
written books about presidents.
I've written books about
famous places, famous events.
I've written a book
about my own mother.
I wrote a book about -- just about
the most famous song in the world.
Anybody know what that is?
What? We Shall Overcome.
And I've written a dog -- a
book about pretty much the best
and cutest and most
wonderful dog ever.
So yes, what are you pointing at?
Dozer's run?
What are you pointing at?
Yes, We Shall Overcome.
That's right.
So more questions and
then we're going
to have you all come and meet Dozer.
Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
Where's Dozer's Mom?
Oh Dozer's dog Mom?
>> His dog Mom.
We got him from a breeder
in Pennsylvania.
So they have her.
>> Debby Levy: So Dozer's
Mom is in Pennsylvania.
>> I have a quick question for them.
I'm wondering what their favorite
thing about Dozer's story is?
What do you like most
about the whole story?
>> Debby Levy: Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
That he runs with people.
Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
He likes people walking him.
You liked that about him.
[ Inaudible ]
You like that he likes
helping people.
That's a big one.
Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
Why else is he a special dog?
Let's hear it.
[ Inaudible ]
Because he's a therapy dog.
That does make him very special.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.